this first question is really stressing
me out because I hope I can say it
without giggling but I want to know your
personal opinion who do you think who'd
in the P bucket oh my God Jasmine I
think it's Taissa I I think it's the
evil time I like that I like that yeah
yeah 100 yeah she's gaslighting everyone
yeah yeah but she doesn't know because
it's the other house yeah that's what
I'm saying it's the dark side that's a
good theory going in the trees unless
I've taken you know dumps in the bucket
I was thinking at a point maybe it was
crystal like if she's not if she's not
fully flushing the toilet maybe she's
just like whatever it's my job anyway
you know what I let's blame Crystal too
here's my one other silly question for
all of you who would you which three
famous people would you invite to your
slumber party oh oh my God I'm Batman
someone else started off okay okay okay
um okay uh I've gotten to work with her
before but Viola Davis come on over
um I'd love to have a sleepover with you
Robin Williams come on down yeah we'll
take and
um Shirley Temple let's have a combo
yeah
um Jesus sorry call Michelle we can
cuddle
oh she's like Pedro
oh it's the daddy party
can you tap this oh no that one and
we'll add some extra fun ones I am all
for giving that one all the points in
the world all right so Courtney I'll
give you this question about episode one
so this will be uh released after
episode one comes out I'm really curious
from your perspective what it was like
playing the moment where Lottie screams
before she gets on the plane because you
gotta know at least in the moment if if
you don't know what has happened in the
wilderness up until that point where for
you in that moment on set is that coming
from
um pent up like emotion sadness I don't
know I'm an emotional person no it was
um interesting because I had a little
bought nationally wore on his head that
day and I was asking where it was coming
from and at some point I was screaming
at the uh reporters and coming from that
type of Rage of get up get out of our
faces and then there was another one
where I was screaming out into the Ethan
maybe towards
um the Wilderness but it was daunting it
was our first day on set it was black
house
um I think I lost my voice a little by
the end of the day but um yeah yeah this
is one of my favorite like scene cut to
opening title credits ever it's just
great song with it Pitch Perfect Pitch
Perfect I'll stick with non-spoilers for
you Samantha because I've been keeping
this in my back pocket since we last
spoke what is something about nuha as a
scene partner that you really
appreciated and maybe even helped you
access something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
without her oh my gosh
she is like the cutest little sweetest
thing and I love her so much and I think
that the way she looks at me honestly
she does though she kind of has those
like puppy eyes when she like when when
she's Crystal
um that I can't help but be like oh like
you know what I mean like I feel like I
turn into a little kid when I'm like
playing with her when I'm acting with
her and I think that that's a big thing
between Misty and Crystal is like they
are kind of like little girls hanging
out
um and so yeah it's it's not hard to
like fall in love with her and be really
weird and Goofy like there'll be times
like right before the scene that she'll
be like
baby and I'll be like yeah and then
they're like and actually there's times
where like you're doing things even in
the background where it's not the focus
of a scene but it's so important to
filling out the world and making all the
characters feel around I'm like you're
also on point with this stuff is so
brilliant that she would be like she'd
look at me and be like okay should we
sword fight and I'm like yeah like you
know what I mean like she just come up
with these things where she'd be like
let's hold hands in this and I'm like
she comes back from a theater background
no yeah yeah she's just freaking amazing
I love her so much I'll throw that
question to both of you now too just
because I love talking about the value
of a good scene partner do you remember
a time on set where you were having a
tough time cracking a scene but because
the person you were acting opposite gave
you what you needed you were able to to
see it through and crash um I don't have
like any
specific partner but I just know because
I think the relationship with everyone
is so different but I do think it's
really interesting to see how the scene
comes alive when we're all together like
sometimes we'll be doing a scene and
where like something is just off like
something in the Rhythm I don't know who
it is like not someone I don't know who
it is but something it just doesn't work
and then we'll discuss and be like I
think we need to just pick up amp it up
pick up the pace and the way that we all
like collaborate and like unite together
to make the scene work I think that's
the most impressive I would say I would
say that Samantha and I had a scene
later in the season that
they're a bunch of things going on
physically and mentally in that scene
um and we had some fun it was the first
time we had really got to be one-on-one
a lot of this season is groups and we're
starting to break off and do one-on-ones
but yeah sometimes it's like the most
subtle things like I think sometimes
we'll do a scene that yeah or like
Courtney will come and we'll just be
like put her hand on my shoulder I'm
like oh and that gets to me it's like
the tiny little unexpected moments that
really yeah actually I have a really
good one that you didn't even
intentionally do is just I think
everyone on this set gives
the most they can and especially going
into season two we were all nervous and
I remember talking in the green room and
us being like we need to forget the
pressure and just kind of commit to what
we want to do
um and I think everyone committed so
hard and then especially later in the
season there was a scene where Sophie is
almost looked like she was having a
panic attack and I almost stopped the
scene but it got me to where I need to
go